[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pas plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non ça n'est pas mes heures
c'est bien evelyne thomas et là vous
vous dites mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait
en 40 pour touche par touche pas oui il
fallait dire touche pas à mon poste on a
vous a pas briefé c'est la journée des
droits des femmes et vous le savez baba
à lâcher le manche pour me tendre une
carotte que j'ai saisie voilà j'ai une
femme a aussi un cerveau une
présentatrice qu'on sait pas mais qu' il
ya quand même que trois femmes en
plateau non mais oui mais c'est le
respectent pas les quotas
[Applaudissements]
mon papa tu vois ça l'espère mais jamais
dans la foule n'en a rien à [ __ ] de
blessure vraiment blessé bien évoqué
l'île entre le discours et les couleurs
médias ça fait mal sort
[Applaudissements]
j'avais des doutes parce que c'est très
difficile on a été leader comme qu il
est encore à la radio et en télé de se
mettre dans une banque comme ça et
d'accepter et il a eu l'humilité de le
faire donc ça c'est remarquable
matheu
je signale la vague ça va pas sans lever
1 faisant un peu plus engourdie j'ouvre
la laisse permettrait donc les
journalistes
attention à ce que vous et climat
électrique et les crises aube
oh là là c'est pas bon
allez qui est bien traitée pendant lé ba
oui mais c'est bien tout le monde était
bien concentré
cyril danois allan baekke nea
ouais la gamme allegra
cyril hanouna et experts médias un rire
et chansons voilà bonne vanne de
bretagne tirer aussi moi je sais rien je
sais que familial mais ça ne juge pas
les vannes des coiffures couilles je
disais qu'il avait eu l'humilité de se
mettre dans la bande
on s'en fout ce que c'est vous qui
devrez mener ses missions non ce n'est
pas tant c'est le patch mais n'en suis
pas le patron du verbe stage à serre et
paco rien du tout ce que je ne garde pas
mal de mer
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car j'ai quand même
pour moi c'est mon choix dans les bacs
depuis sun moitié alors des paniers
garnis s'est très bien intégré bravo
[Musique]